hey where we going
get out of here the same way we came in
the central grandmas okay
pick that up actually okay oh yes
best ever
shield
Wow
die man what are you still alive well
over here
who's nicer to me jumped up so that none
of his burswood how you don't check
okay step on in man this is the best
lift ever do we oh sorry being off my
brother's secret iconic in a word it was
torturous well that they have our face
excellent truth is broadcasting on the
move it'll make it much easier to track
oh oh oh what's going on okay
oh my god oh my god was that was that
yeah that's what I thought it was yes
oops what do you mean you lived through
that no you didn't are you kidding I'm
just leave through that get to do that
okay energy shields have recharged
oh damn it yeah not about okay we run I
wonder if this'll even walk might not
even be able to get through without
killing them all dead hunter going ah
not equipped to deal with you right now
that was good no please don't blow up on
me uh
just alright I'm supposed to be
I honestly don't know
oh come on die seriously die what are
you doing this time yeah weed guard come
this way now honestly not too sure what
i am doing but i'm doing things missed
him well that sure he's pretty no it's
not yes it is no it's not okay back up
and he'll it went through him what
that's my own stickies is supposed to
work there's an exit nearby hurry okay
maybe so nervous stop it stop where are
you where are you Jack stressed me out
so much pretty good is he dead you dead
thanks always do around me not to worry
it's pretty sloppy stuff I guess they
never expected a hostile intelligence to
penetrate their network from the inside
seems vaguely correct if you could give
me like a yes or a No let me real nice
what ah this way this way covenant just
destroy to round ships and I'm hearing
reports of small arms fire throughout
their fleet creatures of the Covenant ah
critics I was on my little slipspace
rupture it's in ever class yeah
calm down wookie
I could just leave him find themselves
right like I'm doing first-person
shooter on why not trying to kill
everyone but I don't elect to take that
approach if I can if I can avoid killing
people why would I kill him thunderstone
that jobs man oh god I hope I just threw
a sticky grenade whoever doesn't kill me
too yep I fine there are those who said
this day would never come what a day to
say
that would've been pretty sweet smacking
that guy out of yet but I was just two
days he's very was sure I repetitive
guests probably cheaper they design
everything exactly the same and they
have to get it like the plans approved
once you know you tested one one of the
hallways with the doors oh my god i hate
here oh um and then yeah you don't just
do it again real good it's the best
that's a real cute I feel bad for doing
that I shouldn't have done that I don't
want to get involved man just passing
through
not hurting anybody feel like I've been
some kind of paradox am I stuck here
forever is that the point I'm never
gonna get out i'm just gonna be on these
floating bridges for eternity is that
what's happening okay this looks like an
inn ah shitty through
like I know it's a bad show before it's
even landed like I well screwed that up
ya know leave me alone oh damn it oh I
got him I have no idea how that happened
I have to go down now and get up that
without what have to do yeah she was
hurt I'm so thankful for the whole not
much full damage thing feels weird on
having a sprint button though just
suppose hello to just didn't but feels
wrong
Wow probably wasn't necessary
I feel so evil shooting them when
they're running for me yeah am I one of
my beaker else is locked okay no it's
not was I supposed to do that
how do you live through next does not
compute take a shortcut straight through
the mausoleum look on the bright side
for now that's true that is a distinct
bright side
not both alive I have failed this is the
West idea I've ever had but let's do it
it's terrible I should not have done it
does not simply Oh see I've just drawn
the minion now what an idiot I am oh my
god another one nope
so much running
still going
this is locked
where do we go it's locked she's gonna
you're gonna unlock it I thought I was
so smart avoiding all the hunters
apparently not
this music too it's pretty sick
so I'm gonna issue i'm just gonna kill
old hunters
to kill them it'll be kinder to me
the door will unlock man that cool to
watch boss [ __ ] spoke oh hey hey you
know hey don't wow man holy crap i was
getting destroyed
die please stay that stay that way okay
gets right now oh that's locked now that
doesn't seem good okay
so if I'd wha okay I want you suck what
about so fighting are we done
let me go am I messed up can't I go here
we go
oh oh it scared me I don't know why it
went it's like the opposite of them
jumping out at you want to go to scared
they did the opposite of jumping out
they unwrapped reports of blood leaving
in a burqa lads wreckage let's get the
index and find a way out of here before
things get really ugly also mark guys
split them up what are these fender
ah those graphics look at her hair it's
crazy good the hopes of all the Covenant
rests on your shoulders chieftain my
faith is claimed I will not fail Barry
Bertil let him be the great journey it
waits for no one brother not even you
I guess that's it for me everyone thank
you for watching I'm a lot of and i'll
see you guys next time but like